yeah hello and welcome to this video
this is a new 2510 game and I playing
international master a pen man it's not
okay you don't see it here what not the
higher rating front I am but he's
probably new at this new at this time
control so you cannot really um yeah
tell much from the from the rating okay
it's going for the pond she ani what's
their name by the way no though in
Manuel panda vows panda was okay yeah
and he plays the line that supposed to
be unplayable for white due to this and
Queen g5 but it is a very very sharp
line and notoriously tricky this is the
kind of thing that um get if you to read
it is speaking if you could use a
computer you would win one hundred
percent of the time with blackjack but
this is not the case we still have to
have to play ourselves check okay ah how
on earth is this plate okay if I only
have two moves ahead the king is seven
or is it came to the aid okay um I think
it is actually King d8 if i'm not
mistaken
oh let's think about it so my clean is
attacking is rook there's always bishop
age three king d 8 okay Tiki on a eight
I will grab the rook that that won't
work I think it is da this is what I'm
what I'm remembering at least yeah and
now Bishop age three if i'm not mistaken
giving giving him the rook with the
chick but anyway this that's pretty
cheeky to play that it's just losing for
white what clearly worse but you you
have to still play this wacky position
if you don't remember the details which
you of course don't will never look at
this stuff um die yes to go clean d 1
i'm not mistaken yeah can't driving this
stuff and now i think it is f6 but
cannot really remember of course it's a
big Messer we have hit f6 pool so as 6
i'm attacking his his might doesn't have
any great squares to go to
96 check king of seven is completely
fine
cannot defeat he does not have any big
development going for him I don't I
don't really see what he's doing after
have six yeah let's sorry I was a it was
the mouse we all think it f thing it is
of six ideally you still know this stuff
and don't have to find it over the board
but well this has been a while I mean
I've done this in a video series of here
want to want to know exactly how this is
refuted you can I mean maybe I'm
managing in the in the actual game here
but you could actually look it up in my
in my video series that have done the e4
e5 repertoire way I recommend this line
but I produce that I mean roughly
roughly two years ago or something
something like that so I don't really
remember but after f6 I I don't really
don't really know what white is supposed
to do it's a bit strange that he is
thinking about it I mean maybe he just
yeah wanted to to try something
something else something yeah that the
key also it's not not really really
knowing just trying for something
something creative but yeah well it
really isn't any good
you see having he doesn't have any
checks here and this okay 96 but 96 I
just go go to f7 hmm if i go to f 798
check yeah okay i can go to g6 as
community for Checker's Bishop f5
yeah I don't remember how it is
continued I have no idea set of f6 I
probably also had other moves maybe
Bishop f5 or it also makes a great deal
of sense but I don't see him for whitey
anyway I mean what does what is he doing
I'd be three maybe ah that that could be
a problem be three actually hmm i have a
bad fit hunch that be three is good for
him
oh my god that could be that could be
very very painful maybe three is
probably probably good huh b3 I take the
night I should have thought about em sex
I was trying to remember and I thought
f6 is right but be three I take the
night Bishop e3 chick King George's 7pm
that's not ah he can actually go to be
to wear with his bloody King and be safe
yeah if he finds b3 and this is not
rocket science I'm probably toast mmm
damn so f6 was wrong whoo Wow oh that's
all for losing against this rubbish
there's if black plays it right is
winning it's not just better anything
it's just winning effort is have six hmm
one issue is of this f6 move is that I
don't I cannot step out with the king
sometimes king of six could be an idea
anyway anyway if he goes be three can i
still high it somehow I take it Bishop
e3 check yeah maybe I can take we should
buy three checking f7 Queen fa check
king to g6 and this is kind of
continuing this position does this game
I mean it is it is pretty rubbish share
compared to what this should be
you bet ha it's hard to not take only
five actually on b3 if i take bishop a
three king of seven takes on d 8 with
the Queen King g6 he also has CUNY a
check don't have a good square
where I can go to age 60 can probably do
that okay hmm that was that was close
whoo I think b3 was terrible for me okay
now the game continues okay um so um of
course I can just take the night and
probably that's what I should do I guess
tough to not tick is threatening terms
of discoveries what would what else is
there so I'd also some seen a reason to
not take it so um going here and fairly
save I thought or is there something
else I think this is good my bishop 183
is protected by the Queen and I mean I'm
a full of a piece of ham pizza before
two pawns at the moment okay can take c7
but this is just developing me there
should be seven and I'm threatening
Bishop f5 in some situations if the
queen is moving away from me five yeah
that looks good much so that should be
really really okay from him Wow f6 was
bad right anyway I don't even need to
look it up afterwards I just have to
switch on the comp will probably show
how it works
I half a cup of b3 yeah anyway so here
this wide have something my plan is easy
goodnight f6 Bishop t6 and wide resigns
so he has to do something something
quickly yeah I don't know what 25 I have
Bishop e6 Queen h5 check this g6 and
yeah some developing I mean white has no
development whatsoever deform I'm
probably just playing Bishop dyslexia
yeah there should be six queen age 5 g 6
23 check this Bishop f5 check and I'm
starting to unravel
I have no direct threat at this
particular moment so wyd can play a
slowish move like d4 or something like
that thing is I don't see anything that
remotely threaten something
yeah i don't know i mean in many cases i
can also just take stuff i mean over on
d4 for example there is quite I mean
it's there's no reason not to take it to
for example even though I will probe
paper should be six and check get things
developed you can choose six
here that I think I'd rather help me
allowing Bishop f5
check okay check that counter check wuts
ur was okay I guess so um just Knight f6
or anything special here hmm yeah it
looks very very very natural get this
out 92 i can i can also just play Queen
to h3 with the piece of trading Queen
sir it's not bad I mean would like to
play for checkmate here somehow with my
extra material but if it is not not
apparent how that that works i'm going
to win the endgame
nap at home to avoid the Queen's right
now yeah yet here precisely one
opportunity in the game that was this b3
moment after that I don't know it looks
pretty bad
hmm yeah that's a bit late now he has to
trade I guess I Andy's I don't see how
he avoids it can try to I mean take on
age 30 let me take on f3
uh-huh okay that's true that's actually
true i didn't really had this on the
road app this is a move okay um should
be six looks very very normal 94 is
probably the reply
m-m-mighty form it's not no good way to
prevent that
okay I said check actually bishop the
694 I was thinking Bishop takes FTX
rookie aid it's got Quincy for check my
even though what what what is the big
deal okay let's develop can also just
just take h2y am so taking with the
night and it doesn't look so promising
so I'm going to take with the bishop and
now let's see can I can I force them
force the trades here rookie aight i
guess checking you for deaf on f3 i'll
just grab h2
and Quincy for check that Queen to e6
yeah those those ancient lines that are
essentially essentially losing and they
can be tricky to handle because you yeah
you pin check them once and then you
never get it on the board never and next
time someone plays it against you have
forgotten how to refute it and this gets
this is especially problematic in in
blitz chess or sometimes in rapid when
you sit there abdomen to time you know
you're winning or you have a good
position but you cannot yeah directly
remember how the refutation was and
figuring it out over the board so often
tricky as we have seen I probably played
a six a little bit too quickly I wasn't
really sure I was kind of thinking okay
I remember that this is this mean this
is right but it wasn't sorry Iran
recollection yeah I came he's kind of
his dragging this on him we should be
386 don't want to give him any material
into peace for porn
yeah the how to how to do this
efficiently hmm yeah okay you will try
be for a4 b5 something like that I
definitely want to get the H pawn going
so let's start with this right away that
outside passer should be the the trump
card that wins and this is no relation
to Donald Trump it's really meant as an
acid okay so see for who if you go
Bishop b5 now so page one maybe
MP should be five this may be f4 at some
cases mm-hmm what is the best way to to
do this here
yeah maybe it's still back gain the
tempo Luke h8 a rock edge one route 88
and then advanced the pawn after f-450
65 s actually a fork huh I really should
pay more attention
okay rook h8 f4f 94 that's actually a
pretty clean wind so okay let's do that
now I have to be a little bit more alert
yeah it's a typical problem in my play
if I'm completely winning i tend to
relax and feel like okay the job's done
but you still have to make sure not to
stumble into some stupid tricks or yeah
or simply underestimate some kind of
resource now maybe I should have used my
extra pcho to simply kill off anything
on the queenside instead of pushing the
edge point but still should be fairly
clear
yeah expecting b5 trying to get a passer
huh
yeah somehow seems seems searching for
something else even though that looks
like fairly fairly good for white and
compared to two other things b5 abcb
this the ape on my term my tongue be a
threat I go look a eight then King be
three
no it's not I mean it should be a win
somehow but it's not totally conclusive
if it goes b5 at a good aah SI cheeks
okay after wicked King b3 and this is
not able to advance this quickly but
also my each pawn is not making any
progress with the rook on ahead hmm now
that wasn't wasn't very good technical
play
so be five TC takes anything else that I
can do if I really use the pawn yeah
well I'm going and coming up all the way
to h2 but then what
mmm I also feel that man night it's not
really great maybe after b5 I can
relocate the night somewhere else
and cam good where I mean e6 would be
would be good but takes ages
isn't completely easy maybe after be
five six eight eggs okay aight King b3
Bishop g3 to fortify that pawn and then
see that i can get my night improved 97
later somehow yeah i don't like that
much i think i played this badly and i
put in putting the h porn was a bad idea
I should have just made sure that
nothing happens on the queenside keep it
on age 7 and get night and Bishop to
play against the pawns that would have
been technically much better kind of
stunt why he's taking ages him why not
just be five
I mean is there anything else you can
try a five for example a five then b 5f
form f where that's just 94 head that's
totally told layer awful yeah so we went
be five at the end okay is there some
reason why I shouldn't take no probably
not allowing him to take us pretty
pretty weird idea so so okay I'm going
to take it
after see takes root a drug age for a
four he doesn't have f4 adds good so
after rook e8 here rook e8 he has to go
King b3 that quite clear shop g3 where
maybe we should fire
and when I don't have six is really not
a good piece
and one that can do something specific
against him going a five I can start
with Bishop g3 just keeping this this
covered if he goes a five i also have
root b8 that would trade another pawn
well I come on let's do that I want to
take a million years him my technical
play before I probably wasn't ideal but
still should win
the worst that can probably happen years
Bishop Knight shake made which I've done
once before in a 25-10 game
yeah I mean a 5 p-6 really any other
moves
one problem for him as if one of 80
tries to use rook with Ruby one not
something then then the H pawn will
actually move it's not so easy to do
okay so i was thinking 97 it's i need to
really do something with my knight
Knight to e5 for example I mean it still
takes a while until one of his pawns do
something do something serious him
okay well yeah I've rupee eight King c4
that's 95 check and then grabbing
grabbing the CAF three Pawn okay or you
see you check somehow be eight king c4
can also go kinky sex and that so it's
okay can you fix to prevent any King d5
stuff
ok so let's let's try to try to take
things to try to take the f three Pawn
f-for night sea forts also a move for
possible night to the six which it takes
e4 and e5
yeah i guess a six probably
i am not i'm not actually a taking of
three it's just seeing that because of
the pin hmm that's bad
so okay if I go King to e6 Bishop H form
route 88 and a 6 set is that no I've 97
hmm
and I had a pond that's just kind of
dangerous
alright still come on King is six here
Bishop age for Brooke age eight or ten a
697 neg Bishop d3 look each one Bishop
c7 simply a girl's got to call them mmm
like to play it without any of those
kind of strange complications
hmm yeah it's may be difficult difficult
to do to play it without
f-for maybe a form at night have three
men don't really see this leading to
anything for why I mean the a guy has to
go village form bishop edge for gage 8
Bishop d3 something like that or a six
try to give up that give up that Bishop
and hope for the hope for the a pawn
any other moves here so I came the only
alternative for me here would be to take
edge form take f3e but now this is the
side
yeah okay Jade here we go that one okay
nice going out form yeah okay I have no
choice anyway so let's take it um and
now Knight to d7 or to see form what is
that way to play it differently
hmm f2 is also a move I'm just wondering
if I can somehow return one piece to
make the whole thing easier to play that
that sometimes that could be an idea
don't see how though and ok two pieces
are better than one so the night
probably wants to go to to d7 and that
wants to go to the 712 should be that
your help stop there Sean um ok King e7
where's the check I don't ever ok it's
actually not so bad king is having to go
to d aid I'm clicking f7 comes with the
temple this is this is certainly nice
yep Roxy 6s Bishop e7 and if he takes on
c7 I have 95 check the only issue that
is really got a lot of lots of pawns I
mean a lot of balls should be seven
cooked eggs 95 he can he can sec the
rook four for a 4.4 complete for madness
there should be seven rook c7 rook and
age 3 is threatening made but he's got
speed 6 and I don't meet him somehow
really don't ya Bishop e7 Roxy 795 check
Roxy 5 Bishop c5 b6 be six
then look on the first ring and it
should win come on this rupees bishop
against four pawns and Avenue porner I
mean not that they are completely
completely harmless but they don't feel
that dangerous at the moment my threat
he has rook I'm rukan age three I think
that would happen if he goes a six for
example not that I gave him a success
harmless anyway and amazing that it kind
of got got an interesting again is to
grab c7 him I think okay yeah we gauge
3m how is he dealing with the maid I
came King moves don't do it and be six
is just giving me stuff
okay that's it I guess it's a very
important part of endgames mating a text
surprisingly often this is the a
decisive decisive factor that you can
operate with checkmate threats and
tricks and this is enormously helping me
him yet to take on c7 with the rook
p success the only mucho prevent prevent
the median made I think and this is not
exactly exactly helpful
okay so checking it with the night came
to be five rupee three chick then yeah
why not check check check their can go
back yeah that time okay if I take with
the pawn threading to window window a
pawn oops is seven
hmm and also should win but if i click
with the noid go check on a three on b3
King f5 we should be for chick king be
five ships III check
hmm yeah it doesn't seem to be a maid
somewhere can go back to d6 with a chick
King a five chick king I don't have a
don't have a meet fortunately enough
mmhmm yeah okay if I check on a three
first it's just making any kind of
difference check on a three king be five
rupee three check I have check on b4 its
that's actually pretty good let's do
this check mmm nothing else right no but
it's check this check is good check
okay five I can take on v6 check here
and here before check what is it is
actually that convincing I am actually
thought this is it is even better I
overlooked that after rook takes b6 can
actually take this this cake c 7 mm okay
check ya King see three rupees six but
it can take c7 and it still continues
you
okay if I take and b6 with the palm
right mmm five maybe mm-hmm okay if we
check would be six again my [ __ ] trade
night eggs and still continue this this
game
I tick with the a poor Nexus 7's
actually a bit annoying yeah sure sure
to take it on b6 with the pond where did
I give that bloody check I really really
playing the dinner in a pretty stupid
way him this I can do it all right he's
seven
yeah if I take with the porn he was roxy
7 this is a really really annoying if i
move the night it takes on e 7 and takes
my rook which is really really awful
yeah okay come on let's play a move him
and k TQ for now a 70 before
p for a 70 a fort should really do it
right a 7 there's also 95 checks on that
that's not going to work now I have to
really get both pawns weekend minor
piece against Luke unfortunately is a
draw ok now the check and then rope to
the a file
mmm chick here no 95 is good check
night before was possible but I think I
just wind the porn like that and fYI is
also hang thread is night before so
let's grab this we probably will get
Bishop an ID meet again it really it
doesn't happen often but it it seems to
happen here again okay
the 97 and rugae 52 a ticket
check okay so let's let's do this again
yeah we have to meet him in the in this
corner here on a one I have to push the
King back first let's see my test beyond
the square off their other color complex
over the bishop so let's do it like this
just left sometime it's not we not in a
Russian the 50 moves 50 moves so here
are pretty pretty comfortable okay um
where to go now I think we can do it
like that we are approaching the
starting position of there and the
famous w maneuver check it's the check
it's a check right
and you have to play a temple move here
Jay most important is the style of it
the rest you can normally work out later
check this one temple move check check
me and mate yeah it wasn't it wasn't the
best technical performance ever but at
the end it was enough it was this end
game style move 54 and it took about 30
move so we still have some some kind of
um yeah you have enough enough time
let's say in terms of 50 moves to mate
with the sugar tonight so um let's have
a couple of things checked him yeah here
but should be five honey this is um
really a bad move it is the the only way
to describe it the only way to play this
opening is Queen a form after which
black has two main ideas can go F 6 or
Bishop d7 f6 is the stronger of the two
I think and here why it has to be
content with playing something like d3
and yeah here black PESA equalized quite
comfortably okay when he went with this
which is absolutely not playable we need
4 eggs check check King the AIDS right
this this necklace this is a business
pretty much force I mean it's something
that I had analyzed in my in my video
serious the black repertoire so
something to check them if you want to
look at the details up to here there is
not much that white can do that makes
any sense
okay and the engine gives Bishop f5 and
wide resins here so this was them this
was the thing and I feel like I made
this mistake before with f6 probably
made this before this mistake yeah okay
and this seems to win yeah it is known
as winning for black sword that's not a
surprise so what is the what is the
thing the bishop is lining up here and
if white goes be three now i can check d
3 and e choices at least what stockfish
is giving him I mean this is a big mess
but it's also pretty big porn check
that's very important i can escape to f6
where you pawn your point sides clearly
this is what the engine is giving as
relatively best still using i still have
to have to get in stockfish seven years
still use the old version check check
check e and queens or the flag position
but sweet home a piece up yeah so Bishop
f5 this was the the best this is also
given by the computer what is happening
here
check this for example in here check
whoa
what if that's a crazy crazy lon a black
is much better but it is completely
completely crazy
what is actually let me do one thing i'm
back in a second okay I've gotten I've
gotten that book by mr. Bo log on and
going to look that up where is that
that's the Kings gambit where's the
posse on E so let's see I think you also
just push about five I've made my videos
there before that book was released but
I checked this he has absolutely the
same lines um yeah Bishop f5 mmm it
doesn't give 26 though 25 and 93 bored
with the blog win all night a three
that's f6 but you have to go Bishop f5
first huh yeah okay so bish about five
it was I went there six and now b3 is
winning for idea of course a stupid
stupid stupid it took six minutes and
didn't find the move actually I mean
what what am i doing after that yeah
this is the line that I'm just giving
during the game check this is what I
would have done I mean I had to but it
looks pretty terrible he actually is
relatively safe with the king and drank
something like this crying King bee 293
later I went white win so I just wins
and really idiotic him how long did I
take 56 about a minute
yeah I should have really just just
played the position and not try to
remember stuff because when you can
Bishop f5 is not exactly rocket science
this move and be three years is a threat
I mean wow that was a dodged bullet ok
quindi 5 and now i'm jang winning check
even though which I made it check far
more difficult than then necessary I
guess Bishop age 6 giving us better by
the engine no but ok this is not
something that where I question myself
too much it's a pretty winning ending
that that I've played in a pretty pretty
vile oh it felt it felt unconvincing to
me the computer is always on minus 3
year so maybe I'm not going to
completely screwing it up minus 3 all
the way well that seems I didn't screw
it up completely but I had a bad feeling
about something safe Brooke age eight
yeah this is was I thought that this was
still I mean I'm sorry I thought a sixth
actually take and yeah try something
like that because I can't it's probably
not working anyway f4 9003 and I can
still stop the pawns we are doing the
game you get you get irritated j am
Bishop e7 is good a six yeah I was
thinking at this is
this is a more interesting chance and no
take but it still shouldn't work I mean
he ain't something like this and the
pawns cannot move now again that is a
win I thought something like valium I
was thinking maybe hear that that should
also win doing the same job with with
with the roof from the back and yeah
this was stupid it was definitely stupid
I should have won far more easily him
check so this is winning and this is
what I wanted to do originally but I
hear there's a maid that I didn't find
okay yeah so check I felt that one check
check this is made checkmate that's cute
yeah I didn't see that made I calculated
up to here and I was thinking a check
back and hmm here well mm-hmm it might
win what cell but whatever but I didn't
see a maid chan then I miscalculated
this a little bit I was thinking to take
with a porn but I'm sorry um King see
for more oops Kings he falls check and
taking with the pawn and this is
actually not that good I cannot move the
night yeah and if i go here he's
checking me and all the Sun we repeat
yeah or a seven even I don't know wow
yeah it was a pretty bad misjudgment so
I ultimately had to settle for night x
which is win but the night one of bill
would have been somewhat somewhat weaker
of course yeah now I'm happy with that
end game um I've covered this more than
once on the channel but what people
sometimes have problems with is actually
not doing the
winning meeting sequence at the end but
to get the King on the edge of the board
the thing to remember there is that
night and Bishop should always be on the
same color because with that the night
is actually controlling light squares
like this and it's unpaid them light
squares and the bishop is controlling
dark squares so they do a proper job
sharing and manage to with the King
together push the King back this is what
I'm what I'm trying here the night goes
back on that that square now I'm just
trying to check push him slowly
backwards yeah if he would have gone
here this night at seven check guinea
for and then he has to go to the edge of
the board and here we are nearing the
famous w medulla yeah okay well that was
a tough game with that with that moment
of b3 way he could have killed me yeah I
should have I should have thought they
are not just trying to play something
from memory that I really didn't
remember it was kind of on on feeling
and not a good idea you can certainly
calculate this a little bit and cb3 I
did see it I mean after half the after
playing f6 which is definitely a yeah 11
half move too late ok I hope you enjoyed
the game thanks for watching